welcome back to new rock stars I'm Anna
vanston and Nintendo I really didn't
make my job easy with this one we just
got a new the Super Mario Brothers movie
trailer and boy howdy did they pack it
full of stuff because some of the
footage was from the first trailer be
sure to check out my breakdown on that
because I don't repeat myself and thanks
to Rocket money for sponsoring today's
video more on that later okay let's get
into it because we have a lot to cover
first up we have Mario walking down the
hallway towards the battle arena and
already we have hints at what's about to
ensue with the walls lined with Kettle
balls a training sword a barrel a
training dummy that looks like the enemy
Naughty from the Donkey Kong series and
a halberd which seems to be the weapon
of choice for this movie we'll get back
to that Mario then takes a deep breath
before entering the Coliseum that is so
packed that there were even Kongs lining
the top of the amphitheater as Mario
looks around we get a glimpse of a lot
of things most notably the giant golden
Kong and Golden Banana statues that very
much resemble the golden temple from
Donkey Kong Country Returns which is can
conveniently also the centerpiece for
the future Universal Studios Donkey Kong
Country section of Super Nintendo World
we also see several structures that can
be utilized or serve as obstacles like
bricks question blocks crates and tires
which were first made Popular by Donkey
Kong Country the color scheme here is
clearly green and yellow first seen by
those kettlebells in the hallway but
then echoed in the several green and
yellow color Accents in the architecture
and the green banners with bananas on
them more than anything though we get a
feel for the scope of this event by the
sheer number of Kongs and the energy
they're emitting the sporting event
nature of the scene is first heard as
the crowd chants Mario's name but when
we look closer among the crowd you can
also see people with DK's shirts Flags
letters there aren't any immediately
recognizable characters even though in a
recent promotional poster we saw Swanky
Dixie and Diddy among the crowd who
could be on the other side of the
stadium but the types of Kongs in the
crowd definitely feel familiar to the
games I even saw this little guy appear
and thought it might be ditty but no
yeah
no we're then treated to Alexa go before
we're shown Donkey Kong for the first
time Miyamoto said in the premiere for
the trailer that they changed Donkey
Kong's design for the first time since
he became a 3D model and they gave him a
more comical design reminiscent of the
original Donkey Kong we see even more of
this Ode to the arcade game when they
run at each other and we see that
they're surrounded by Red scaffolding
blue ladders and barrels just like the
original Donkey Kong then we see a way
too bloodthirsty Toad and we get our
first look at Princess Peach who's also
really amped to this fight as clearly
recognizable as her attire is this is
actually an original design as the
middle panel of her dress is a different
color than the side panels and the
bottom trim is always a darker color
than the main dress in the games that
seems to be a trend with this movie
it'll give a cheeky nod to something
while putting its own spin on it Luigi
SDK beats Mario's mushrooms to a pole
the side shot we get almost mimics the
2D view of Super Smash Brothers which is
fitting for this fight and game explain
pointed out this specific in-air pose
Mario hits which is the mirror image of
his pose on the cover of Super Smash
Bros ultimate we see a few more details
of the course most notably that they're
above water so everything is safer than
it may seem and there's a little hidden
cave off to the side potentially
referencing the hidden bonus caves in
Donkey Kong Country if I say Donkey Kong
Country 20 more times in this video I'll
lend mow you 10 bucks
then we see what can only be Cranky Kong
as a ruler of some sort which is new not
really sure how he acquired that much
power but Cranky Kong is canonically the
Donkey Kong that appeared in the
original arcade game so maybe he had the
arena decked out and all that
scaffolding and whatnot because it
reminds him of the good old days you
know one of the most satisfying things
about playing any Mario game is the coin
sound effect watching this trailer makes
me want to be Mario I I've always
thought I could pull off a mustache and
when you put that together with this
that means I gotta start collecting
coins if you don't want to smash into
bricks to get a little extra money for
the holidays you should do what I do use
rocket money rocket money is my favorite
all-in-one finance app it helps me
manage my expenses and save hundreds
still unclear whether that'll load me up
with extra lives but a girl can dream
can't she one of Rocket money's best
features is that it helps you find and
cancel all of your unwanted
subscriptions with the app I discovered
I was wasting thousands every month on
stuff I didn't even use with with the
money I've saved from canceling those
subscriptions I've freed up lots of
money for traveling to see my family for
the holidays and traveling back home to
decompress from seeing my family for the
holidays I also really like rocket money
smart savings account and their budget
tool with the smart savings account you
just choose the amount you want to save
and how frequently rocket money will
automatically deposit your money into a
savings fund that you can withdraw from
anytime with a budgeting tool you can
automatically monitor your spending by
category get notifications when you've
exceeded your spending limits and
visualize your spend to earn ratio by
month quarter or year if you're feeling
really ambitious rocket money can even
negotiate your bills for you from
internet service bills to cable and
phone bills simply upload a photo of
your bill and Rocket money does the rest
you can unlock even more features in
Premium Too once you've signed up 3.4
million people use rocket money to save
with just a few simple Taps and you
could be one of them if you want to
start managing your finances the easy
way you need this app to try rocket
money out for free and support our
Channel head to rocketmoney.com
stars or click the link in the video
description we're then shown Bowser
intimidating a captured Luigi saying the
only thing standing in Bowser's way is a
human with a mustache just like Luigi's
which implies he's probably holding
Luigi Hostage to get to Mario also
during this we're shown Bowser's Minions
just partying it up with food and drinks
speakers flashing lights limbo a conga
line distance passed out there also
looks to potentially be a stage at the
back perhaps one that a certain king of
Koopas could perform a musical number
we also see that Bowser has a lot more
variety to his troops here than in the
first trailer in this clip alone we see
koopa's paratroopa swoops piranha plants
dry bone Shy Guy sniff it spinies but
bombs Goombas Hammer Bros and sledge
Bros potentially more and they're
surrounded by Bowser statues which is
just classic Bowser we're also showing a
bunch of Koopas disembarking the ship
into a frozen environment which is
almost certain ly a tie-in to the ice
kingdom takeover scene from the first
trailer no Penguins though Penguins
finally we see Mario in a bathroom I
never thought I'd be so excited to see
Mario in a bathroom there's gotta be a
subreddit for that but Mario in a
bathroom means human world because toads
don't need bathrooms that's what the
diapers are for cowards everybody my HP
snip pants it's the coolest but in all
seriousness we are finally shown in that
shot and the subsequent one that Mario
and Luigi are plumbers working in a
human world at the start of the film
Mario's wrench and Luigi's tool bag
indicating that they are both plumbers
assumably at the same company judging by
their matching uniforms and fist bump
when leaving a job and the whole other
human in the background showing that
this is more than likely the human world
rather than yudong City where people
look different from the brothers these
points are further solidified by another
leaked poster where we see their trucks
as Super Mario Brothers Plumbing showing
they work together and the Brooklyn
Bridge in the background and the street
sign that says Brooklyn suggests this
does indeed take place in Brooklyn in
the real World especially since all of
the new donk city streets are named
after Donkey Kong characters but mayor
Pauline is also in the background so
we'll have to see where she fits into
the picture regardless all of these
details are very reminiscent of the
Super Mario Brothers Super Show which
might point to a parallel plot where
they accidentally warp to the Mushroom
Kingdom while trying to fix a bathroom
drain that will get touched on again
later but after that we get to see
several shots of the interior of
Princess Peach's castle and when we
combine that with the promotional image
of the throne room that was released you
get a pretty good idea of where this
original design draws inspiration from
the main Center stained glass
installation is the exact same design as
Odyssey while the stained glass windows
with the clouds pay homage to the clouds
that line the castle walls and several
of the games the way the serious fan out
is closest to Paper Mario but the
banister is more closely resemble
Odyssey along with the wall detailing
flower arrangements and Throne placement
at the top of the stairs the floor
candelabras are similar to the one seen
in Paper Mario origami King but the
bulbs have the slight shape of the
original no fire flowers we see the
floor is checkered pink and while the
checkered pattern is consistent
throughout the games we have
specifically seen pink checkered
flooring in Super Mario 64 DS and Mario
and Luigi paper jam we also see another
cheeky nod to the sun design on the
floor that's seen in several of the
Mario games looking at the paintings in
the trailer we have a painting of some
toads exploring an area that I don't
believe is specific to any particular
game but might be a place similar to
mushroom Gorge from Mario Kart a
painting of Peach's castle and the last
one is too blurry to make out but
honestly it looks like the floating
islands from the other painting from a
different angle it's hard to get good
paintings these days now there's an
additional painting in the promotional
picture which I think is really
interesting it has the same colors as a
mega mushroom but we've only seen the
specific shape and color once and that's
on the castle grounds of Super Mario
Odyssey the thing that's most intriguing
to me about this one though is that it
looks like the mushroom has a full-on
face to me I wonder if this could be an
upcoming character and this or possibly
a future movie back to the trailer
though we can gleam a lot from the shot
of the toad standing around an
interactive table map these toads
distinguishing a tire make them appear
to be a council of some sort but
although peaches had plenty of toad
advisors throughout the games these
particular characters aren't
recognizable the math are gathered
around just six distinctive kingdoms and
an island that kind of kind of like an
N64 controller there's the Mushroom
Kingdom with Peach's castle assumedly
Yoshi's Island with an egg on top of the
mountain some sort of desert World which
honestly could be a number of desert
worlds throughout the games considering
many of them have pyramids and palm
trees some fans are speculating they
couldn't even make it sarasalan to open
up the possibility of Daisy being
introduced and she's the ruler of that
land we also have Donkey Kong Country a
spooky dark land that is quite possibly
the one we see Luigi running through in
the first trailer and the ice kingdom
that has been taken over by Bowser which
we know is the ice kingdom by that
little corn that hasn't been melted and
the domed kingdom in the middle that
matches the ice kingdom in the trailer
on the map we can also see a little
Bowser Airship with a little star
traveling from the ice kingdom to the
Mushroom Kingdom with the voiceover of
peach saying that Bowser is coming
clearly ready to kick some booty we see
Toad and Peach in an outfit very similar
to her Mario Kart biker outfit strutting
down the hallway before a peach badass
at least Stomps a Halbert into her hand
Halbert stalks are skyrocketing because
there are two sets of helmets and
halberds on the floor we can assume
these were the ones the toad guards had
before something happened
as they walk outside towards the Airship
we see the courtyard with some cute
touches most notably the super Bell
trees from Super Mario 3D Land and the
flowers that are adorably planted in
little red brick blocks so to prepare
Mario for battle and obstacles he will
face in this world Peach has an obstacle
course created for Mario which makes
total sense because if he's a plumber
from Brooklyn why would he have mastered
these techniques already which is
exactly why I was trying to take those
secret parkour lessons mom Hardcore
Parkour we can tell this is still in the
safety of the Mushroom Kingdom by the
hilly background and flag that is raised
styled after the goal pole design
originally from the new Super Mario Bros
the exact flag hasn't been seen in games
before but is pink and it has some mush
and so speech mushroom potato some fun
DIY details you can see here are the
piranha plants are mechanical the
Fireballs are on a rotating arm machine
and clearly not made of fire and if you
freeze it just at the right moment you
can see they Bend when they hit him
which I think is a great detail and you
can see the Bonsai bill is made of some
sort of rubber or foam I don't know I've
never made a bonsai Bill okay as Mario
practices into the night we see Peach
looking exasperated and in this shot we
see light that resemble the super crowns
from new Super Mario Bros U Deluxe and a
metal floor plate around the flagpost
that has stars engraved on it perhaps
emphasizing the importance of stars in
this movie a couple shots later we see
the trio crossing a bridge with cheap
sheeps flying at them which is likely an
Ode to the cheap cheap bridge in World
2-3 of Super Mario Brothers or perhaps
world 6 1 of Super Mario 3D Land either
way Mario and Toad seem to be getting
more action here than I have this entire
year our next shot is a bonsai Bill
headed straight towards the castle with
Mario and Tow at the beginning of the
shot we can see from an aerial view of
the castle that the surrounding
Courtyard has six star-shaped areas we
theorized in the first trailer breakdown
that Bowser might be collecting stars in
this movie and this shot and the sixth
definitive lands that were on the map in
the earlier shot could indicate that's
how many stars he's after we then see
Mario determinedly flying in a Tanooki
suit with the Bonsai Bill chasing him
now normally Bonsai bills fly in a
straight line once fired but since he's
at the same level if not slightly behind
the Bonsai building in the previous shot
when it's headed towards a castle it's
possible they broke the rules a bit and
made it heat seeking to allow Mario to
steer it away from the castle Danner
it's a different Bonsai bill I don't
know after that we see the trio in a
huge field of fire flowers and a cool
detail here is that before peach touches
the flower her dress is normal and in
the next shot it changes to her fire
Peach dress oh the details she also has
a line here mentioning how there are a
lot of galaxies which indicates we're
definitely going to be getting a Super
Mario Galaxy nod which I speculated
about in the first breakdown as well in
this section we also see glimpses of
various lands including a Sunset View
over Cliffside that distinctively
resemble the rock structures from rock
candy mines in New Super Mario Brothers
U and the scene from what looks to be
Yoshi Island the scenery looks like the
beginning of the game Yoshi's Island but
also as reminiscent of Yoshi Village
from Paper Mario and even though we see
every color Yoshi in this huge horde of
Yoshi's running this guy chilling we
have yet to see the green and white red
shoe Yoshi that we all know and love
then we see a beautiful shot of what I
assume is the interworld between pipes
unless Mario got a soul punched out by
Tilda Swinton but this shot is very
similar to the cutscene in Super Mario
3D World where they travel through a
space like this and far off we can see
pipes to other places in the background
we see Luigi who still has his Plumbing
bag placing it at the beginning of the
movie frantically flailing and calling
out to Mario although they grab hands on
the trailer since they're seemingly
separated for the rest of the movie I
have to imagine they're gonna give us a
Kingdom Hearts soaring Kyrie moment I
can't talk about it and because they
didn't cram enough in for me to dissect
this trailer rounds out with a
referential Mario Kart scene okay let's
start with a location the waterfalls
Greenery and cliffsides could be
influenced by various Mario Kart levels
like DK jungle or shy guy falls but
there's also an interesting detail in
the background on both sides you can see
a red track in the distance and on the
right side you can also see what looks
to be maybe a wooden mine entrance as
well there are a few games they could
have pulled from here the reddish track
could be from Toad's Midway Madness from
Mario Party 4 the mine entrance makes me
think of the minecart levels in Donkey
Kong Country games and in Donkey Kong
Country Returns there's a Minecart Track
where you go from a cave to the outside
and in DK jungle in Mario Kart use zip
around cliffsides and there's even a
section where you go through the golden
temple although this might be influenced
from the games it's definitely an
original design and will almost
certainly be utilized in the movie
they're also driving up a rainbow road
which is definitely an homage to the
several rainbow road courses in the
games this one most closely resembles
the Mario Kart DS or Mario Kart 7 one
although the colors are reversed it also
looks a lot like the Rainbow Road Mario
and Luigi drive up to to get to Bowser's
Castle in Paper Mario Color Splash and
when she also collects six stars we'll
sign now looking at the carts they're
driving Mario is driving a version of
his standard cart from Mario Kart Wii
that emits blue Sparks as he drifts
which is a feature in Mario Kart Peach
is writing some sort of hybrid zip-zap
sneakster and mock bike toads in a
modified Tiny Titan and all the Kongs
are driving a variation of cards that
vaguely resemble the bolt buggy from
Mario Kart 7. no one took the super
blooper huh more for me the cards have
various weapons installed onto them
making Donkey Kong Country the black
market for carts apparently the card
Donkey Kong is driving has DK rocket
barrels from DK Country Returns on his
cart and there's potentially a banana
Barrel attached to one of the carts in
the back as well you can also see a
couple cons that look familiar in the
background behind Mario is a Kong with
Shades and a bandana that looks a lot
like funky Kong and off to the left of
the frame you can see a small Kong that
looks a little bit like kitty Kong we'll
just have to wait and see if those are
the actual characters or not the whole
gang generally looks pretty happy
driving together telling me that this
particular scene is probably not a race
like I said earlier in Paper Mario Color
Splash they used the rainbow road to get
to Bowser's Castle so that could be what
this group is using it for as well but
either way their expressions seem to
indicate that they've teamed up at this
point and are off to save the world and
Luigi but like and that's the trailer
now as I'm filming this they've released
another trailer so
if you want to see a breakdown on that
just leave it in the comments Below in
the meantime you can follow me on
Twitter at it'sanna vanson and follow
And subscribe to new rockstars at new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love and since the Super
Mario Super Show plot has officially
been introduced I'm into the outro we
should all do the Mario
um
[Music]
thank you
[Music]